I last saw you know when you presented
at the Billboard Awards and so you know
something happened to me and I had no
idea what's happening well that's a live
show right yes okay so very do many
quick changes oh my god well I do in
this kind of the story kind of goes
along with that yeah so they've got her
just a little sort of context they she's
hosting the show and they've got her
you know they mean running back and
forth back and foot there's no time to
stop you are like a freight train man
coming and going I feel like Reba in the
90s with all the changes its own real
yeah but I'm standing there and you're
coming through and you've got this train
on your dress
yes and you're flying by and as there's
this dude that just kind of he just we
have the technology can I stand he just
he just stands like this and he starts
talking to someone and he stands on your
dress and you're flying by your I mean
you're like a shot and I looked up in
quite would have been a different show
yeah it would have been brought to you
by spank that's right yeah and I just
looked at him I didn't know the guy but
we just connected somehow I made eye
contact it was a dude thing and I was
like raise your right foot and he
literally just felt like he looked at me
and goes Boop then he raised his right
and you booked and you were gone oh my
gosh literally that would have been like
a very different version of single lady
that whole look would have been I have
thank you from the bottom of my heart
you're very welcome and we are racing in
and out of Arian sit something like that
happens all the time so thank you yeah
you're welcome
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this